- [Narrator] What we have here
is a diagram of a food web
that shows us how matter and energy
are transferred between
organisms in an ecosystem.
But it's a little bit abstract,
they don't tell us what
these organisms are.
They just say organism one, organism two,
organism three, and so forth.
But even this gives us some information
about which organism are the producers,
the primary consumers,
the secondary consumers,
and the decomposers.
So the first thing I want
you to think about is
which arrows show us going from producers,
I'll write it like,
to primary consumers?
Pause the video and think about that.
Which arrows show producers
to primary consumers?
All right, now in a food web,
the giveaway that something is a producer
is that it doesn't have
arrows coming into it,
it only has arrows coming out of it.
And so organism one is a producer.
Organism five is also a producer.
Where are they getting their
matter and energy from?
Well, they're getting their
matter from the environment
and the energy, in most
cases, is coming from the sun.
And the things that eat the producers,
those are primary consumers.
So this is an arrow that
goes from a producer
to a primary consumer.
This is an arrow that goes from a producer
And this is an arrow
that goes from a producer
to a primary consumer.
Now, with that out of the way,
which arrows show us going
from a primary consumer
to a secondary consumer?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, I just said that these things
that are consuming the producers,
these are primary, I'll
just say P for primary,
primary consumer.
This is a primary consumer.
This is a primary consumer, as well.
Now secondary consumers are by definition
things that aren't decomposers,
but they're eating primary consumers.
So they're going to have arrows coming in
from primary consumers and out
to either other secondary
consumers or to decomposers.
So organism three right over
here is a secondary consumer.
So we're going from a primary consumer
to a secondary consumer.
So this arrow is from a primary consumer
This arrow over here is interesting.
It's a secondary consumer being consumed,
but you can see that organism four
only has arrows going into it,
which is a pretty good clue
that this is a decomposer.
So I'm not going to call
organism four a secondary,
a secondary consumer.
So let's keep going.
What about the arrow that
goes from organism six
to organism seven?
That looks like primary
consumer to primary consumer.
Well, it turns out that something can be
both a primary consumer
and a secondary consumer.
So this is also a secondary consumer.
Why, because it's eating
a primary consumer
and it's not a decomposer,
so this is also another example
of an arrow from a primary consumer
to a secondary consumer.
Last but not least,
what are the arrows
that go from a consumer,
that go from a consumer, to a decomposer?
And we already broke
this down a little bit,
no pun intended.
Pause the video and try
to think about that.
Well, this is the only decomposer
that's depicted in this diagram,
and so this is going from
a consumer to a decomposer,
right over here.
This is from a consumer to a decomposer,
and that's all we have here.
And to be clear, you don't have to go
only from a consumer to decomposer.
You could have gone from a producer
straight to a decomposer.
You could have arrows that
look like that, as well,
because if a plant dies
and it gets decomposed,
well, it's going to be,
that matter and energy
is going to be used by that decomposer.